ladies and gentlemen it is with the
utmost remorse and respect that we
mentioned Ethan Klein of the H3 podcast
announced that is this clip from today I
believe so in in a clip that was posted
today he has no sponsors because he is
an existential threat to gay people in
his own words I believe in his own words
I would like to play for you this clip
from the H3 from the H3 TV uh video here
we go
I'll just say this let me fix the audio
very thankful to our members it makes
this show kind of uh
bulletproof no sorry Gary Stans here we
go
today we have no sponsors because uh
uh I am an existential threat to uh gay
rights
and all progress
so of course our wonderful uh fans have
taken upon themselves to write all of
our sponsors
and to have them uh
can't uh not sponsor or not to support
us so
that we are um
I'm very you know
I'll just say this it's a I'm very
thankful to our members it makes this
show kind of uh
Bulletproof
to stuff like this even though it's
painful and emotionally it just doesn't
it's just painful that you know people
would do that
okay I want to say a few things
um first Ethan is correct about members
and that's why we said we I wish we set
up the website years ago but you you'll
learn when you learn and had I known
what I know now I would have been like
that was that should have been the first
thing we did because once they started I
mean the censorship was a big problem
for a while we had videos taken down
that's why we we dedicated to this I
will say that um you know Ethan mentions
in the clip
you expect more from the sponsors and uh
he's right he's right about that too you
do you do but um I will also add I
genuinely do feel bad for Ethan I think
he doesn't understand what he's involved
in I think he didn't he doesn't know
what the world's become I think he's
genuinely been lost this whole time so
let's go back in time to January when
Ethan Klein deleted episodes with with
he had with Jordan Peterson
he clearly did this because he was
panicking about getting canceled he
doesn't want his business to fall apart
so he's just like okay fine dude I'll do
whatever I have to Ethan you should have
just stood by your principles which is
edgy comedy free speech and having
conversations with people
we have never had one of our show
sponsors cancel on us pull out on us in
fact the first sponsor that I had ever
had on YouTube virtual Shield sponsors
us to this day no issues despite all the
controversies the lies the smears the
manipulation and I will stand by what we
believe in and what we say and I'm not
going to play these stupid games
Ethan started playing the games getting
scared panicking
he chose to get into business business
with these companies and now he is
sitting there saying it sucks I have no
sponsor well look man you gotta stand up
for yourself you can't let these people
push you around you should not have
taken down the Jordan Peterson episode
because you look duplicitous you look
like you're lying and you look desperate
and so I hope it works out but hey man I
can only say if you want to get in bed
with people who will Who will uh push
you off that metaphorical uh
Cliff at any moment
well then I can only say like you should
have you should have prepared for this
you should have expected it you knew it
was going to happen if imagine this
imagine if Ethan Klein instead of
deleting the Jordan Peterson episode
came out and said they're telling me if
I don't delete this episode they're
going to pull my sponsors pull them I
will not take down the conversation with
Dr Peterson imagine how much he'd be
supported oh you get 100 000 more
followers that subscribe to his network
is I hate to say I Told You So Ian if
you hadn't just embodied the archetypal
hero oh my goodness I've been sitting
across from this fellow for too long
apologize for that error I hate to say I
Told You So Ethan if he here's what he
did he said to the people who try to
threaten you by having your sponsors
taken that he will comply he said yes if
you are somebody who is sponsoring my
work I will dilute my message and walk
back things I've said in the past once
you've told me not to you're inviting
control at that point and also
I want to point out that when you
cultivate a fan base full of people who
would cancel someone guess what happens
to you eventually you get canceled it's
not that complicated
if if uh I feel like this is a guy who
got started doing edgy comedy on Reddit
and YouTube yes things like that and
then as times went on he thought I just
better say what they're saying the
problem is once again this is not
mainstream America he is bending the
knee to Weirdos Jordan Peterson is
popular among regular people the people
who don't like him are The Fringe
weirdos regular people do like him
So when you say I'm going to take it
down because he's a bad guy you got
tricked Ethan Klein got tricked and now
what's he gonna do you know I'm seeing
everyone on the right mock him and and
they're laughing about it Jordan
Peterson told him that eventually he'd
be held to a standard uh by the very mob
he wishes he currently wishes to please
then you will make a mistake and they
will devour you with Glee please take
this warning seriously I liked you Ethan
should not have sided with those seeking
destroy he should have sided with those
seeking to protect and to develop
because if he came out and said I like
talking Dr Peterson on more than one
occasion I may not agree with everything
he has to say but we have to defend our
right to say these things then they'd be
like we're going to harass your sponsors
and he'd be like okay and then people on
the right would be like we got sponsors
for you buddy don't worry we appreciate
you standing by your principles and
doing your thing but too too much Ethan
has been drifting into just saying
whatever the left wants and and look at
what happens you know he did that thing
with Hassan
you want you want you want to live with
people like you want to work with people
who will destroy you in two seconds by
all means you go ahead and do it but I
don't know I don't know what I can do
for you when your life is destroyed by
these very people we can supply
technology that you can use Ethan in the
future for direct subscription content
so you can bypass like patreon and crap
like that take control of your network
we'll do it we'll work together man I
like you I am real quick on the the
issue with our stream
um I'll get every message I'm getting in
is people saying that the minute it
stopped was right when Ian started
talking about Intel collection via
social media yeah it's hard to tell I
said even it was like the CIA but
there's no way yeah
shut them down yeah and then it just
immediately stops and someone I think
may have pointed out foreign networks as
well because what I'm talking
intelligence is it doesn't have to be an
American wait okay well you just said it
again okay but but and he should be to
be fair
um you know Ethan Klein he gets canceled
by the left and loses sponsors we call
out the CIA and then our stream just
freezes in Midstream so right you know
you got to choose the American
government we are the good guys I'm even
down with secret agents
look you need what you need to do is
obviously because he's now a free agent
apparently because Malcolm Nance is no
longer working for MSNBC you need to
sign him up as a special foreign
correspondent for timcast for timcast
IRL would you sign Malcolm Nance no
but why why because racism is he's a bad
person did he actually go to war is that
what happened he wasn't he was an
intelligence officer but no he's not an
intelligent officer he was never in a
naval intelligence officer he never a
naval intelligence officer Wikipedia
says he was he was a Navy Chief which is
not an officer and he was a linguist
he's not he was that is not the same
thing Wikipedia was wrong oh my God no
uh he he's he's got a picture of himself
like he's in Ukraine with like tactical
gear you saw the video right yeah where
he's like looking at his watch and he's
like the missiles they're coming it's
South Southwest stand by Stand By and
he's like he's like one of my dad
everyone else is just sitting there like
dude everyone's like walking around the
background my dad you know when we were
little he used to you know you know when
you hear the the lightning and thunder
and you can you know count how many
seconds between the flash that's like
one one thousand two one thousand and
then but Nance is doing that for
missiles they're flying over that's a
cruise anti-ship missile it's coming
from a ship
towards us now and everyone's like okay
dude like you're you're fine like like
it's yeah we know like we're aware I
want to talk to you guys about twisting
Universe you time to go yeah
we should talk about
um Ethan having him on the show well
Ethan's welcome on the show but I don't
think he'd do it because
they never want to actually there's a
lefty guy who's tweeting he's dming me
right now like why why aren't I on the
show here's the issue with with the left
as we often bring this up prominent left
personalities always have an excuse as
to why they won't come and do a show
yeah um it's always Ben Shapiro yelling
debate me or at least the meme right but
when it comes to the left they're like
I'm not going on your show or they'll
publicly be like I'll go on a show I can
do it yeah so your whole thing with uh
Hassan the other day yeah because uh he
said he would come out and come on the
show but then he dm'd me and he was like
hey bro like covid I'm you know I'm
pretty scared of kovid so I don't want
to do it and I said I get it man that
was that was the the first time that was
the first time right and then this time
he got mad because uh Hassan tweeted a
joke David Pacman said do you know
anybody who's pro-abortion I uh Hassan
then said me I'm trying to do this David
Beckman said that sounds weird someone
said what's wrong with more abortions I
screen grabbed that and posted with no
comment I thought it was funny I thought
the whole interaction was funny no
comment and Hassan responds with dude
it's a joke man do you need me to put
slash S and I'm like I didn't say it
wasn't a joke I literally just reposted
what you did right so then he made a
tweet about how you know me and Dave
Rubin or whatever and then he I was like
we claim to claim to be progressives or
true progressives and or or like were
people who are rallying people who claim
to be true progressives and I was like
I've never said I was a progressive I am
not a progressive I am a Centrist
moderate and he's like you're literally
doing what I'm making fun of you for and
I'm like dude I was like that's not an
argument you're welcome to come on the
show and give a conversation and then
all of a sudden I'm not coming on your
show I I won't do it and then I was like
oh here we go here we go
you know so we got a guy who wants to
come in the show and he was he right he
was saying because you're another part
of the country and the travel and cut
into my Twitch streaming but but you
know he agreed to do it before and kovid
was the reason and now it's oh I'm too
busy and I'm like dude I can respect if
you're busy it's hard for me to travel
to go to people's shows I still bought a
trailer we drove down to Nashville and I
went on a bunch I went on Candace's show
on The Daily walk I went on their Sports
show and I went on Backstage Live I will
make that happen and so I was like dude
I'll get the trailer we'll bring it to
La it'll be really difficult but we'll
figure that out spend a week in La maybe
I don't really want to how's the drive
to Nashville by the way oh it's fun it
was nine nine that looks that'd be nice
my Blues Traveler a few times my purple
circle good guitar amazing guitar and
one of the best songs I've heard in a
while uh by Nickelback the Devil Went
Down to Georgia and I am being
completely serious I cannot believe that
was actually Nickelback he actually put
it on before the the episode and it was
it and I I I I'm saying this live
it's good the callback's good you
here's what the ratio is we've got
somebody on the left they're like the
people who want to come on the show that
are on the left have like no followers
they're not particularly prominent
individuals they're I get I get messages
from people who are like I'd love to
come on the show and I'm like dude
I'm not saying you shouldn't come on the
show just because you have no followers
because we that's not the prerequisite
for being on the show but it's the body
of work and typically there's a
correlation between someone with you
know uh who's not particularly prominent
and a limited body of work for which we
can actually comment on and then what
happens is you bring on someone who is a
limited body of work in a low following
count and when you end up destroying
them in a debate the left then says the
only thing you could do is bring on this
guy who's like not even that good
because he couldn't get a real debate
and it's just like
I got no problem we'll have we'll have
we we've got a few people come on you've
had people come on that only have a few
thousand followers because followers is
not the reason we've had people come on
with no with no social media and things
like that I'm just referring to body of
work and you let Ian come on yeah all
right of course yeah you know the first
time I was ever invited I really had to
have a long debate with myself about
whether I wanted to platform Tim I was
like am I promoting this I know right I
got a feeling that a lot of people are
afraid that if they come talk to you
that you'll bring up like information
and over like just destroy them with
like not destroy but fact take them to
town with information and facts and then
they'll feel like an idiot and look
humiliated when in fact they can just
come hang out and just like learn but
the problem is like do you guys remember
when Hunter Avalon was on the show
yeah yeah he tried challenging me on the
Ukraine story with Biden and I'm like I
was like wow you're really gonna was
this one he was trying so he because he
like got big as like a conservative and
then he tried to like Veer really hard
to the left and this was after he was
already now but he was like I mentioned
the Joe Biden you know well SOB I got
fired he's like that didn't happen and I
was like yeah he's like no I didn't and
I'm like here's the video and then I'm
like bro don't come here having done no
research but acting like you know these
stories I've dug in and done so much
journalism on this stuff the problem is
with people like him and uh is that he
sees memes and thinks Tim pool has no
idea what he's talking about just
repeats right wing talking points when
literally all day this morning I was
digging into the The Washington Post
story looking at public records and
doing legit hours of like real research
and journalism I make phone calls I do
the work it is it is rough Mayo gate I
love this story actually called the
restaurant I call for comment we do this
all the time I reached out to Taylor
Rens for comment I reached out to the
Washington Post for comment our Newsroom
did at this stuff we do the research
these people see these memes and these
meme clips and they're like the right
silly talking points Dude shows up here
and says Joe Biden never said that I was
like are you kidding bro did you even
Google it here's the video and I played
it and he's like oh that really happened
and then I'm like let's talk about my
clothes my clothes let's talk about the
formation of Prisma let's talk about the
former CIA CIA guy who's working on
there let's talk about gas problem dude
you do not want to get involved with me
I was in Ukraine I went there I watched
those protests happen I'm not going to
pretend to be the expert of all experts
on this stuff but man for these people
living on the internet doing no research
then they finally come here and it is
like getting hit slammed by a tidal wave
where it's like oh wow boy do they look
bad and the problem is for many of these
people is they want to maintain this
facade of I'm on the left well what
happens when they come and sit down with
Steve Bannon and Steve Bannon goes text
the rich and they go I agree Steve
Banner yeah and then all everyone on the
left is like they were agreeing with
Steve Bannon there you go that's one of
the big problems I know the last left
does not like you know what you know I
think is good Destiny was it Stephen
Bonnell III because that guy has no
problem telling it exactly how he thinks
he's not gonna do it once though and
that's fine but because he he accused me
of not of lying about being in the
military I'm lying about being in the IC
and I did not take that well when when
he came on the show he has no problem
and it didn't go over he knows the
stories he knows what he thinks about
him we just disagree and I'm like I can
respect that but there are there are
many people where they think they're
going to come on this show and they're
going to be like you're you think this
about race and I'm like no I agree with
you on systemic racism and they're like
you do and I'm like yeah do you watch
this show and they're like no but I saw
memes once so this is one of the reasons
I think they really do not want to come
on the show Hassan will come on the show
you know the last thing I said about
Hassan before that tweet thread was that
he was right there was a story that came
out I can't remember exactly what it was
it was months ago and I was like he was
Julian Assange I think I defended him
because people were ragging on him about
Julian Assange and I was like Hassan did
not like was make a joke about a son she
did not literally say this and I'm like
it's silly we don't need to go after him
blah blah blah just because and then the
dude gets mad at me because he doesn't
actually watch the show if Hassan came
on this show he'd be like what about
this and I'd be like I agree and Ian
would be like I agree and Shane was like
yeah actually I I agree with with the
details of that I made his Grand policy
and then what's he gonna say what's he
gonna argue about all of a sudden the
narrative is going to be Hassan goes on
timcast and agrees with everything
they're saying he must be far right yeah
just talk about your past man let's
learn about where it got you to video
streaming and into it you used to work
for The Young Turks like what's your
relationship with chank when you guys
are young you know that kind of stuff
let's just let's just show humans that
we can interoperate and still have
differing views I tweeted at him he was
like why can't I go on zoom and I was
like we don't do Zoom internet makes us
hate each other it's better to sit down
shake hands and talk about it and that's
why we do it the way we do Andy no hit
me up and he's like can I do your show
remote and I said sorry dude can't do it
then he came here Lauren Southern can I
come on your show remote I said we don't
do remote you can't even do it in person
Lauren like we don't want to see you
around here yeah and well uh
even for Andy know and Lauren Southern I
was like what about Snowden
I I don't want to do it I really do not
want to do it I I remember watching Joe
Rogan's episodes where he did zoom and I
was like not fun yeah the episode is 30
million views because it's snowed that's
that yeah I don't do this for 30 million
views like I want to sit down with
people and talk and even when we have so
would you go to Russia to interview
Snowden the problem assuming you know
travel was was fine and all oh two
seconds yeah the the real issue is that
I can't run a business while flying to
Russia you know what I mean yeah we're
trying to get to that point exactly what
you mean why are you scared of debating
Snowden so you won't debate Snowden then
you're terrified I would I would love to
debate Snowden and say that you
published documents without going
through them and redacting critical
information and that was a serious
intelligence risk I don't view uh what's
known as a whistleblower if you view him
as a leaker because he did not actually
review the documents that he was giving
away uh and he's admitted to that I can
respect that he admitted to it I think
the distinction is important he did
expose a bunch of really important
things that's fantastic but I think
terminology is important in
understanding what someone did someone
who sees malfeasance and says hey you
guys got to know about this
whistleblower someone who says I see bad
stuff I'm gonna take all of it and just
give it to journalists I'm like leaker
different thing you know he did blow the
whistle technically what about Manning
then Manning was a whistleblower
collateral murder that was incredible
but but didn't Manning still grab a
bunch of doctors there were a bunch of
doctors if it depends I don't know
exactly I'd have to research the Manning
stuff the issue with Snowden was that
Snowden has admitted to being like I
didn't read this and it's like okay well
then you're just leaking stuff that you
don't actually know what you're putting
out there and I think it was actually it
might have been John Oliver who was like
in the documents You released there was
unredacted critical information that put
people at risk and he was like I didn't
check or I was no he was like uh it was
published by the journalists they failed
to redact and he was like I didn't I
didn't know and he's like shouldn't you
have to like is that your responsibility
and so I was like yeah that is I guess
so I can respect that thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalist employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there